oh well KBO victory of the Daleks I
consider this to be an underrated
episode I feel like it largely gets
forgotten or I think that the new
paradigm Daleks are over maligned
I may do no I will eventually one of
these days dedicated video on on them
specifically but I'll touch on that a
bit here but broadly speaking what do we
got well we have a Mark Gatiss penned
episode which usually are not to my
liking and it's a Mark Gatiss historical
set episode which usually are really
really not to my liking not that their
necks necessarily flat-out bad it's just
the way that he tends to approach the
historical settings and figures just
it's not my bag it's not what I'm here
for
but I actually kind of like this one
pretty well I mean Churchill is enough
of an overblown figure that I don't mind
him appearing in a bit of a caricature
stay cuz let's be honest from what's
known about the man at least his public
persona it was a bit of a caricature of
a human being at times I think
deliberately almost he tended to really
play into that sort of perception of him
so that performance is really good Amy's
great in this she's really clicking with
Matt Smith their chemistry is terrific
and Smith does a really good job
you know confronting the Daleks for the
first time you get his frustration at
this initial set of like what is going
on why won't you just try and kill me
what are you doing offering me tea you
know his frustration with that and then
his
the sense of defeat he has by the end of
this thing
as for the Daleks themselves honestly
you break down what it is they're doing
this is one of my favorite uses of the
Daleks in new whoo I'm serious straight
up now they overstepped majorly on one
specific issue but I'll come back to
that when I start talking about the new
paradigm Daleks but broadly speaking the
Daleks and how they're used and what
they do I think he's awesome and it's
what I wish we saw the Daleks doing more
of so it kicks off kind of nicely too
because the previous episode had ended
with Churchill calling him saying doctor
I need you to come and help me with
something we see the shadow of a Dalek
so we know Daleks World War two okay
cool he gets there and turns out the
Daleks are already fighting on the side
of the Allies being passed off as
artificial soldiers as Ironsides created
by this inventor now one of the things
that I like about this right off the bat
is it's continuing the trend of Matt
Smith's doctor not being great at
piloting guitarists usually being a bit
off he showed up a month after Churchill
tried to call him the first time and it
does actually also kind of really
highlight how eager amy was for the
chance to run away because she the last
two times she saw him leaving that
machine he did not come back when he
said he was gonna come back so the very
idea that when she went off with him you
know two episodes ago that she's like
you can bring me back here just a few
minutes after we left right sure he says
yes and he probably means that he
definitely intends to but everything
she's seen is that he will not be able
to do that and yet she still goes so I
like that they're keeping up that he's
not able to do that and it serves as a
reminder for you know the fact that Amy
did just run off with someone who may
not be able to get her back and she
probably knows that a lot better than
she is letting on
um and I really like Amy's sense of
adventure in this that the doctor then
has to temper because he's dealing with
the Daleks and the Daleks are not fun
not for him at any rate at their best
they can't be fun for us the audience so
we have the Daleks posing as fighters
until they get what they want out of the
doctor where the doctor shouts at them I
am the doctor and you are the Daleks
testimony received this is what I mean
when I say this is one of the best uses
of the Daleks and why I really love some
of the specific things in this episode
because the Daleks in knew who while
they would occasionally have grand plans
and schemes it was always on these
massive scale so yes they had plans but
only because the things that they were
trying to accomplish were so huge they
had to have plans you know the the thing
with stealing the earth and to make that
but they're not subtle they're not
clever about it
they brute force their way through these
plans even the cult of Skaro was very
much brute forcing its way to attempting
to force their own evolution but here we
get the sneaky Daleks the scheming
Daleks the deceiving Daleks something
that we tended to see a bit more of in
classic ooh but we have seen very little
of in knew who and I love that it works
that they trick him and because he
doesn't know why they're here or what
they're trying to accomplish he plays
directly into their hands and as soon as
they have what they want
they let the facade drop drop so even
though the doctor does not initially
know what it is he just allowed them to
do he knows he screwed up he knows that
he is somehow managed to play into their
hands and I love that I honestly okay
now let's get to the new paradigm dog
first of all I actually like the
and I liked the color coding it I don't
think it's necessarily better than what
had been done with the new modern Doctor
Who reinterpretation but I like it
honestly I like that they were
designated with specific roles we had
the scientist the strategist the drone
the eternal I still want to know what
the heck an eternal Dalek is what does
it do I do and and of course the supreme
and after this really the supreme was
the only one that would ever turn up
again
and I think it's a shame because I think
if we had gotten the chance to learn
more about these specific things and
what they do in roles you could have had
them show up and we could have known
on-site
what kind of Dalek we're dealing with
and what sort of stuff they're liable to
be pulling and I think that could have
been cool but I'll talk more about that
at a later date you know really
extrapolating out from it but overall I
think the paradigm Daleks are totally
solid where they screwed up in
implementation and where I totally get
that people don't like them it's not
from people just don't like the color
coding which I mean I do but okay it's
the fact that they had them destroyed
the Daleks that we already knew and
loved this is literally the exact same
mistake that Jurassic Park 3 made you
remember that one you remember how they
introduced introduced a newer bigger
tougher dinosaur the Spinosaurus you
remember how the way they showed that it
was the biggest and toughest thing
around was by having it kill a t-rex the
dinosaur that everybody already loved on
the assumption that somehow we would now
love the Spinosaurus because it killed
the thing we liked yeah that's not how
this this works it didn't work for
Jurassic Park 3 doesn't really work here
either and I also don't think it was
necessary I think the new paradigm
Daleks could have taken command you
could have even hinted at the
possibility of their now being a power
struggle between them and these existing
dogs but no instead we're just gonna
wipe these out these are the new guys
and I think that was a fairly big part
of what contributed to the harsh
backlash
that was so harsh we never even saw
these dang things again yeah that is
annoying for me but like I will
absolutely admit that was an overstep
and they dropped the ball on that
particular element and if they hadn't
done that I think this idea would have
been better remembered because this is a
totally solid idea I like the concept
again I like the way we get there and
the way the Daleks trick the doctor I
like the the way that the doctor tricks
them back with the jammie Dodger you
know there's bits of fun to be had here
unfortunately after we get the new
paradigm Daleks debuting things I don't
want to say fall apart but they just get
a little ridiculous and I mean doctor
who can be ridiculous and sometimes it
can be very arbitrary what does or
doesn't like feel legitimate but the
Spitfires flying into space feels like a
stretch the the Android that had been
passed off as the human inventor of the
Ironsides who apparently didn't even
know he was a robot he's a bomb okay
that's totally something the Daleks
would do cool
he deactivates his bomb miss by feeling
lots of fields shuts down the bomb so
he's not a bomb now because he felt
I'm not gonna say that I can't go to
some degree with the idea that him
tapping into his humanity would somehow
break whatever restraints the Daleks had
to keep him alive and made sure he did
what they wanted him to do and you know
properly freed him but having it
actually deactivate a bomb that I have a
hard time imagining the Daleks wouldn't
have rigged up to be completely separate
from whatever was going on with his
brain and fit in fake as far as they
were concerned fake emotions and it just
it just feels like a bit of a stretch I
also strongly suspect that it's here not
because this story needs it but to
introduce the idea of an artificial
human being still being validly human
because that's gonna come up again later
in later in the season so I strongly
suspect that's why it's here in the
first place and I can't prove this or if
there is evidence of it I haven't found
it cuz I don't really do research but my
suspicion is that the inclusion of that
angle was a directive from Moffat
because he saw it as an opportunity to
set up some stuff that he was gonna do
later on in the series or at least set
up some of these concepts and lay some
of the ground work because within the
confines of this story we we don't need
it it yeah it just doesn't it doesn't
quite work it doesn't quite fit and it's
a little it's a bit cheesy er than what
had come up - well I mean it's about as
cheesy as the spitfires I suppose but it
really did feel like wow the Daleks are
winning you know the doctors doing his
best but he's on the backfoot the doctor
the Daleks really have him now and now
they're Spitfires and a bomb robot with
fields so he's okay now it's a bit of a
it's a bit of a jarring shift tonally in
terms
what the sort of level of reality is for
this episode and doctor who can get away
with adjusting the woeful suspension of
disbelief and sort of the reality of the
story from episode to episode but when
you have it shift like that within the
same episode that that doesn't work so
well and it's a shame because like I
said I actually think there's a lot of
good in this episode I think it's an
underrated episode truth be told but I
also recognize the problems with it and
that it ends with a soft very soft hit
like the the shutting down of that of
that bomb is not the cathartic climax
that this thing needs because I mean we
were dealing with the Daleks and we end
with aging human robot is gonna go look
for the town and the girl from his
memories to see if they're real I mean
yay but it just it it's not the climax
and the feel and the conclusion to a
Dalek story if that makes sense but
victory of the Daleks you seen it lately
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments and let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of stuff to do as well
because you can like you can subscribe
you can support me on patreon which
helps me cover the bills and and ideally
one of these days get to legitimately
start doing bigger and better projects
and plus there's other stuff down below
as well link to the book I've published
oh the patreon also gets you on to my
author diary because I'm working on
another book of work of fiction this
time and author Diaries are going up on
the patreon page and yeah I plugged that
enough but there's other links besides
that socials Instagram Twitter etc etc
click on stuff it'll take you places
check it out or don't I'm not gonna tell
you what to do because at the end of the
day you're the council
just run in the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]